Thì đổ vàn đức dưới video về đề thi thử sự cao bằng liệu 2 cao tạm có dễ đặt điểm cao.
Khiber, thì bởi vì ở sống game bế tìt được,
sẽ cao bằng sau đây sẽ sẽ đánh làm một chút về kỳ đề thi này,
thì game thấy mấy 2 có đồ tiền thì chúng ta thấy không có câu nào đăng chú ý cả.
Phần 2 thì kỳ có một trời câu sẽ cho mình chính thức.
Mà phát triển từ đề diễn đứa, nhưng nó sẽ ơn.
Nhà, tôi 2 là một câu không dị đàn nói cả.
Câu 3 là một câu cũng không có cực kỳ kỳ kỳ kỳ kỳ dễ đàn,
và game thấy nó kỳ câu này kèm làm rất nhiều dôn.
Nếu mặc game muốn cho khó hơn,
nếu bắt đi bằng muốn cho khó hơn,
nếu là sẽ lấy nhiều cú hơn,
bây giờ 1 2, 1 2 3, 1, này để game xem các buổi,
mà thật là sẽ vui các bạn bị cho bà dỳ đàn.
Tôi mời tỏng sất mà thế dạ.